cada día carmen dedica unos minutos a
escribir en esta libreta todos los
pensamientos que le ayudan en su proceso
de recuperación
amurallar el propio sufrimiento es
arriesgarte a que se devoren desde el
interior mi diagnóstico es un
trastorno depresivo ansioso recurrente
llevo desde los 16 años medicada en
españa la cifra de especialistas en
salud mental es muy inferior a la media
europea no puedes tener un intento de
suicidio que te den ahora para dentro de
3 y 6 meses o sea es que no puede ser
teléfono contra el suicidio dígame
algunos de los recursos que tienen las
personas con y de acciones o conductas
suicidas son las líneas de prevención
el gobierno español puso en marcha en
mayo de este año el único teléfono
público contra el suicidio hasta
entonces han sido iniciativas privadas
como ésta las que han suplido las
carencias estatales en un país en el que
cada día se quitan la vida 11 personas
es escalofriante y desde nuestro granito
de arena intentamos ayudar en la medida
de las posibilidades para que todo aquel
que esté desesperanzado y que quiera
ayuda nosotros cogemos el teléfono e
inmediatamente
ayudamos por cada persona que se quita
la vida otras 20 lo intentan las
organizaciones que luchan para frenar la
conducta suicida llevan años pidiéndole
al gobierno de españa' una estrategia
específica contra el suicidio piden el
mismo trato urgente que han tenido la
violencia de género o los accidentes de
tráfico
tenía que hacer a nivel de educación de
servicios sociales también de sanidad en
formación de profesionales en acceso a
medios letales en educación emocional en
cultura general sensibilización en
medios de comunicación todos coinciden
en la necesidad de hablar abiertamente
del suicidio para que deje de ser un
tabú y pese a las dificultades
carmen no duda en mandar un mensaje de
esperanza todos sacamos una fuerza luego
interior que te hace remontar el vuelo
como si fueras el ave fénix una fuerza
que hace que cada día se convierta en
una nueva hoja en blanco